steven strasberg is ready to go the 32
year old san diego native who makes his
home now
in the dmv facing ronald acuna junior
leading off
and strasbourg will bounce back and get
a bouncer to trey turner on two hops for
the first down
plus kari noah who started a handful of
games last year for the braves by the
way used 14 different starters
you know was one of them and did pretty
well in that assignment
lined softly to short dansby back pedals
and robles is retired one up one down
austin riley
banning fifth of the order in game two
for the braves
wow that's carving up a right-handed
batter
first k of the day
[Music]
little three pits see ya
that curveball mesmerizes you doesn't it
just watching the replay with the exmo
seeing the rotation on it
change up
pulling out the whole toolbox here early
stephen strasburg two consecutive k's
after three ground ball outs in the
first okay watch the movement of this
one so look on the fingertips decelerate
turn it over and just subtle right one
down for aaron perez
swinging a miss
you know has got it working his first
strike out of the day perez didn't get
that two up two down two for 14
to start the year right-handed hitting
rookie center fielder
here comes the changeup
wow
off the table change-up
so dan three of the last four by the
net's co-ace strasburg had a decent year
at the plate in 2019 he had 12 hits
including a home run which was a grand
slam against the braves
the 3-2 swing a line drive right center
field base hit for strasbourg this one
up the alley it's gonna roll to the wall
strasbourg digging for second ponche
struggles to pick it up and throws it in
late and it's a leadoff double for
steven strasburg
the nationals first hit for a pitcher
since 2019 in strasbourg
with an extra base hit his 10th career
double
[Applause]
robles takes the walk
2-1 one out for trey turner
[Applause]
chopper and toradzi flipped to dance be
one can they turn it they did
boy that was slick
quick feed from ozzy albies to dansby
swanson and a laser beam gets turner by
a step they waste a double by stephen
strasburg and waskar inoah is through
three scoreless here is poche the
centerfielder who struck out
his first time up
there's the change up unhittable
number six
i mean we've seen up here we watch this
change up for uh 10 11 years now and we
sit we do the same thing every broadcast
but i feel like today it's exceptional
it's a different level and maybe it's
because we haven't seen it so long it's
the newness of the season but i feel
like it's got a lot more side to side
movement than it normally has
stick six strikeouts bunch of contact
outs
sort of protecting that pitch count
as we get into the latter part of the
game here soon
this one is hit well
soto back inor retired you know
sometimes you have a slugfest other
times you just sit back and watch two
guys dealing that's what we're seeing
right now
perez garcia and barrera do up
no balls two strikes
swaying and a missed ball in the dirt
perez will be thrown out that's for
strikeouts and a new career high for
inoa in innings
came back to get his man that's a new
career high in strikeouts
two up two down in the fifth inning and
barrera the eighth place hitter is
scheduled for the nationals
on the ground right to shore dansby's
got that lost star inoah 68 pitches and
five shutout
innings well i mean this is the ending
for stephen he's pitched brilliantly all
day long
0-0 game in the top of the sixth i mean
this is the ending if he wants to get
the win he's got to get through this
inning
got him on the inside edge
with a 93 festival
strikeout number seven
[Applause]
swing
and a miss 93 upstairs
number eight
and it'll be strasburgin freeman
freeman swinging on 3-0
uh what a good scamper over there by
perez the versatile infielder
steven strasberg retiring 10 braves in a
row
standing up get up at home and give the
guy a standing o what an outing for
steven strasburg if that was his last
house
this is where you're thinking double or
ball four
it's got to be your pitch right down the
middle
that's a good bat
lead run aboard with one out turner and
soto
the next two hitters
delayed steal by robles
shuffle shuffle in a way he went on a
pitch in the dirt
yeah i didn't see that i was like that's
the best read of a ball in the dirt i've
ever seen because i looked up but he was
almost a second
i took my eyes off it
watch the delay steal i love it
game on here we go
and trey with a fly ball that will play
for acuna
roe tagging acuna on his way in
and victor speeding over to third the
throw hit him fortunately for the braves
it bounced right to the pitcher jackson
backing up third base
so it's up to starlin castro in a righty
righty matchup with two out
anna chopper
jackson to freeman
natural strand a couple they've left
four
hits hard to come by in game three of
this series
pablo with an opportunity here in the
seventh inning of this ball game hit the
home run on opening day to tie the game
and now gets this opportunity with a
runner at first and two down
there we go
swing fly ball hit towards center field
deep robles back to the wall pablo does
it again
to the deepest part of the ballpark and
no doubter
everybody's kung fu fighting as the
braves take a two-nothing lead shawn
newcomb will seek his second career save
his last save
was back in 2019 against the giants in a
4-1
phrase victory
pablo sandoval as we told you hit fifth
for san francisco that day and the o2
pitch
he struck him out and the braves sweep
the double header
what an incredible final inning for sean
newcombe and the braves pablo sandoval a
two-run homer a strike out of the side
and jeff the braves sweep a twin bill
win the series and will come home two
and four after their opening road trip